The Dr. Seuss collection is really
what Ted Geisel
(otherwise known as Dr. Seuss)
kept in his own home and his own collection.  Green
Eggs and Ham was the book
that he was dared to use only 50 words.
He usually started out with something
that he calls the "bone pile"
where he began to work on
the words and how the rhyme might fit
together
and then in this particular volume he's
got the color
overlays for the book and the colors that
he's going to want in the final stages.
They will shoot from the black and white
sketch
and then the printer knows what colors
to do and what percentages. You can see
the difference here just on the overlay
were here it's a hundred percent yellow
and forty percent yellow. And also adding
little notes to himself as he goes along.
"White inside the hambone, always" and then this
is another one where you can see
the black and white sketch and the story
I could not would not on a boat I will
not will not
with a goat